Barney was it all it was it at all
heartening to hear you to to you to hear
Donald Trump acknowledged violence
against the LGBT community no because he
did it in a very limited way he's
protecting us against a former ideology
in the 45 years I've been involved in
this
the number of foreign ideologues who've
attacked us is like smart was a terrible
event but they were very specific
homegrown bigots they have free reign
and he also is said I'm going to go back
to the Supreme Court he has announced
that his model for the Supreme Court is
in Antonin Scalia who was the most
important homophobe ever the whole Halle
office in America and you appoint an
Antonin Scalia to the United States
Supreme Court you have done more to
unravel the gains we have made anything
else so no that was like a lot of other
things in that in that platform cover
they opposes everything that would
protect us against most of our
oppression and he's going to protect us
against the foreign invasion okay
Cornell as Obama's tournament office
comes to a close have you rethought the
impact of his legacy at all because I
know you had a lot of problems with the
brother Barack
also not where enough for you no but not
a man of purity don't matter consistency
we don't confuse those two priority has
to do with not being human all of us are
human beings integrity has to do with
human beings questing for some beyond
just sheer cupidity love with money and
love of status now what was the question
I know it away but what a mere a butter
but I'll put it this way I always look
at the world through the poor black
child poverty today 47 percent of all
black children in the richest nation in
history the world under six live in
utter poverty to meet us a crime against
humanity it has gone up it has gone up
under Barack Obama but it is on but not
only like wasn't Barack because but have
you heard him give one speech at eight
years old child poverty yes where was it
I've heard him talk to Congress about it
and I'm gonna time up the poor words I'm
not the public my brother well it's not
secret when he talks too much and the
problem isn't groceries had a Republican
congressman of course you can this but
he can hit and hit get are separate he
had a bully pit he can you well he's
hoping he can't
he kind of pissed on white cake we got
my pass on yeah we are what is shaping
the climate of opinion change me I'm
gonna get changed
you're not gonna help poor kids by
making speeches that the Republican
Congress votes against we have to elect
people who will vote the right way much
too much power to politicians
politicians are not to politicians to
the voters nominate this big mistake the
donors are not static the voters have to
have their minds changed politicians you
truly do have one Dunham stood up for
gay rights at the national level you are
outwardly that's why they didn't slant
up they didn't want to lose go back to
the rhetoric that doesn't us what it is
now is just the fact is that many of us
are trying to Bernie Sanders was trying
and again I'm sure a tional level I am
shocked by how frequently and complete
you and I repudiating Bernie Sanders
opposed apologize I'm not burning yet
both sides going I'm referring hitting
one side you were yeah he wants you he's
got both sides we get inside outside he
fairly quitting your for Gil Steiners no
wrong in them but he's usually my
brother if I did but he just roan that's
all it says let's ask one more question
and get to the drinking given you guys
are gonna get along a lot better
Martell one question yes well now I have
one question
yes ma'am you'll say well Jost I know
appointed Supreme Court justice I
understand you want to be for her now
you're going to bring them up if three
weeks before the election it is very
clear that it will be either it will be
written or Donald Trump there Jill
Stein's efforts or debate whatever have
not worked if that's the career choice
will you vote for Hillary Clinton it
would be an anti-trump vote yes
where some flowers for me didn't like me
but hated my opponent I wanted to kiss
them right well I think I'm very special
circumcised that only ten states in this
country or swing states yes voting third
parties is not a hard thing for me to
fathom living in the state of New York
Donald Trump is not going to we thinks
he could win New York he thinks a lot of
things get you one careful Johnny Donald
Trump I think given the vileness of his
campaign I want to see a large majority
against him in the total but there are
people good I want him to get to evoke
he's ever gotten and the amazing thing
about this election is that we don't
know nobody really knows I mean Trump
could win in a walk or Hillary could win
49 states
I just don't know and that's what's so
scary about it thank you very much
everybody
you